good afternoon my name is Bernard Baruch
told image and I'm a medical director in
a RUP laboratories and I will talk about
exome sequencing as a diagnostic tool
and I use exam seekers in in the
clinical laboratory for several years
and in this talk I bollocks I will talk
about and share my experience about
Excel sequencing before I start I wanted
to get a couple of housekeeping items
this analysis for the secret siiii
credits you can go to buy conference
live com for the ce credits and also for
the questions if they come to mind
please submit your questions to me while
I'm speaking so that I can address them
at the end of my presentation in this
talk first I will give a big round about
the method and then I will show your
data analysis using an example cases and
then I will talk about guidelines and
recommendations about a exam testing for
professional organizations exome
sequencing is a result of the investment
made from human genome project its
president omar obama states that was a
good investment every one dollar
investment return hundred and forty
forty dollars to the economy of course
this did not happen overnight but it's
certainly gained momentum in recent
years the nice structure was discovered
in nineteen fifty three and twenty years
later Sanger sequencing was developed
and it took another 20 years to sequence
one a human chromis
however it's just a couple of years to
sequence an individual's genome of the
development of next-generation
sequencing exome sequencing is a
powerful tool for gene discovery over
200 genes have been discovered in a
couple of years and those were most
recent research studies but now exome
sequencing actually is accepted as a
powerful tool for diagnostic as well
part of this is the cost next generation
sequencing costs is dramatically
dropping since 2008 in this graph y
plane shows the projected cost in years
and the green line shows the actual cost
if you look at the last five years cause
of sequencing wrong [ __ ] base of DNA
dropped from one thousand dollars to
depend sense other than cost the amount
of data produced by this technology is
also very attractive so I wrote exome
sequencing to the pump meds is a a
keyword and then I got more than 200
papers since 2010 this shows the trend I
wanted to get your attention in this
last article publishing human mutation
2013 and authors discuss that
acceleration seekers in will be
replacing Sanger sequencing in clinical
diagnostics course is a really major
factor for next-generation sequencing
and really can replace this angle C
concerning the future for example
fibrillar months one gene is a one of
the large genes has 66 exles so let's
compare Sanger sequencing a few billion
one gene by itself
and as part of the arrow to put the gene
panel this is a month on and mark on
racks and drums gene panels which
includes few billion one gene and nine
other genes the cost of these two tests
are very similar so most Commission's
prefer to order next-generation
sequencing sa instead of feminine one
Sanger sequencing by itself by exome
sequencing we mean sequencing of all
exons of the genome but we are missing
some parts of the genome those are some
protein coding genes some excess of some
jeans non jennique control element some
micro RNA genes copy number changes
structural structural changes or
sequencing of mitochondrial DNA as low
exonic reaches of the genes are parts of
the genome we understand best although
one person of the genome are exonic
regions eighty-five percent of all known
cause disease-causing mutations are
located on exons so exome sequencing
costs but one in the six of the cost of
horrid genome sequencing so by exome
sequencing actually we are getting the
most useful data with the lowest cost
although selection of cases is a heat
effect on their clinical sensitivity of
the test diagnostic yield is around 20
persons based on NH undiagnosed disease
program
but we should not fold it this is a
diagnostic Odyssey for the patients most
of these patients have multiple
congenital abnormalities intellectual
disabilities or unexplained
developmental delay or declining and
they have already tested negative for
many tests there are some political
considerations for the exome sequencing
description of clinical findings and
inheritance mods mods are the key
components of the success available
affected family members and good family
story is also very important there are
some analytical considerations for eggs
on testing as well so like a capture
efficiency or by uniformity of aspects
which I will cover with examples of by
infrared gasp it's a lot in the next
necks of the slides and also there are
some post analytical considerations for
Exxon those are you this is really the
very hot topic with lots of discussions
for example is that I really negative
example port did the patient cause them
to learn about everything or adjust the
primary findings there is a need for
education our patients conditions and
also payers so I will come back to this
issues and address some of them using
the regulations and guidelines first I
wanted to talk about little bit
methodology so this is a really long
process it takes about a month and there
are main steps involved and automation
is really necessary in the victim site
of the laboratory to minimize the errors
the first step is sharing the DNA
so we can eat you can use several
different techniques to share the DNA
you can use sound waves in this example
and you share the DNA another 200 base
pair fragments the second step is
library preparation so after DNA is
fragmented the ends are repaired and
adapters are ligated you are not getting
two different adapters on ends of the
fragments this will allow have to pay it
and or single and sequencing the goal at
the end is to amplify this fragment for
sequencing here is the example of the
successful ligation in the first graph
you show you see this the fragmented
pieces around 150 base pairs and after
the adapter binding you see most of the
fragments are are around 120 a 50 base
layer so this indicates of success
library generation the next step is an
enrichment you can use several different
capturing techniques in this example
usage or any bait capturing so the
probes are designed to capture all
excels in the genome and also exon
intron junctions so in this example we
have to donate by automated our innate
base and the DNA when we hybridize by
automated on a base with the DNA
then we use victor wooten coated
magnetic beads to separate the the
captured DNA from the leftovers and then
we sequences targeted traitors after and
in this example you show a you see the
flow cell and and just a cluster
generation step two different adapters
are attached to the surface of the flow
cell you see the colors with the green
and blue we hybridize DNA fragments to
the flow cell the other ends of the
fragments also bind to the flow cell to
make that bridging step and by several
cycles of the bridge amplification you
see on the left side of the bottom of
the figure and we make the clusters the
cluster formation actually allows us to
read several copies of the same
fragments so one fragment one cluster
and we can several copies of one reads
this cartoon shows how the sequencing
occurs in the single fragment primer
binds to the fragment and one nucleotide
incorporates at a time and this week low
tides have reversible dye terminator
after binding the image is captured and
then the title manator is created this
is a one cycle so if you 800 cycles that
represent actually 100 base pair wheels
so this is an example of the single base
pair and reading this is capture of one
of the cycles at the flow cell and this
is how the flow cell looks like a during
a cycle if you flip the flow cell from n
read from the other direction this is
called period and reading read from
other side of the fragment to this
allows to increase the read coverage per
cluster more accurate reading in
alignment detect small and large
insertions and deletions and inversions
are other arrangements better if you use
appeared and reading at the end after
all these steps the fun starts data and
analysis is really challenging so in
this slide I just wanted to show you the
coverage and reads the blue boxes
represents the excellence of gene and
gray bars represents the individual
fries so here is a zoom in of the same
region on using the ID readable program
to see the real reads the again this a
grey bar represents the real individual
reads in this example actually we see an
italy-based a base substitution it's a
from the t to see change as you see some
of the reeds has the wild-type allele
with the tea but almost half of the
roots will represent to c allele so
there is a heterocycle change in this
example data analysis starts with
alignment of the ribs back to genome the
use of combination of several programs
can help to clean up the data decreases
the false positivity Xin negativities
however the most difficult step is the
interpretation since this there is no
software can do this except a human
being after all steps you're done and
you have the variant calls and at the
answer you have a thousands of the
variants at the end to analyze for this
patients the variant filtering out of
course is the different the first
logical step to start with but the
filtering is really tricky so you have
to really set up frequency cutoff depend
on the disease disease prevalence this
is penetrance or inheritance pattern of
the disorder as well so some diseases
could have a low penetrance and you have
to set up your frequency cutoff really
high that you should not miss their real
notation in the sample
and based on my experience the most
powerful filtering is actually the
family members and i will show you some
example in next couple of slides however
we can filter out based on the
inheritance model location of variant
and reading type as well which i will
show you the examples too let's look at
this studio this is an 11 years old male
and he has a global development of a
short stature feeding problems hypotonia
hypoplastic to natalia and loss of a
dismal fusion dysmorphic field features
including facial features as well so he
doesn't have any family history and he
has lots of laboratory work is done and
they are all negative such as sleep
microarray fish for the George Pradel
only subtly rearrangement or revision
tybee syndrome he is a normal karyotype
and normal EEG in brain MRI and we
received this patient sample with the
patient and also his healthy parent as
well for exome sequencing so based on
this pedigree we thought we could a
analyze the database a autosomal
recessive pattern or Dino autosomal
dominant pattern or x-linked pattern so
realize this data based on all these
scenarios and I'll show you the result
oh sorry I did not have a say
I was a movie died sorry okay here is
the here is the example using the
autosomal recessive inheritance model so
this patient if we don't use any filters
and anything at all this probe and his
around 57,000 variants so on the
autosomal recessive inheritance model he
can use the population frequency around
four persons and so we filter out one
person of the population frequency and
also we kept only the variants are on
codeine or splice site regions and those
are the ones that nonsynonymous stop
codon small French's in favor changes so
we're really looking for a disease and
lots of possible pathogenic mutations
and this patient is 915 variants based
on this filtering then those are our
sisters a recessive model we have to
focus the homozygote of the same
homozygote rotation for one gene or
compound heterozygous mutations in a
gene as well so this patient is 53
homozygote mutations and fifty compound
heterozygous mutations that possible
possible
this is cause invitations then we use
the parent to exclude the variance
filter out we feel throughout the
variance if the parent are homozygous of
any of those so and now from the 53
homozygote variance this patient now has
eight homozygote variance variance and
that we use another filtering and then
we feel throughout the variance if both
petitions in the same parent so we will
be looking for validation in one
chromosome the other mutation and the
same gene shall be the under second
other chromosome for this patient to be
able to disease-causing on the recessive
model so this patient had a 50 compound
head but we did not know the chromosomal
phase and when we include the
chromosomal phase using the parents
information then then we hit ended up
only 15 compound hits possible mutations
for this patient and this is the example
for the Dino of inheritance autosomal
dominant model on the dot autosomal
dominant model he may actually change
the population frequency filtering and
then lower the frequency and one in
thousand so we filtered out all the
variants more than one in thousand and
then we only look the variance again in
like liability for daily recessive
coding in supply-side regions and focus
on the nonsynonymous stop codon small
frame [ __ ] or in frame changes we ended
up hearing 528 variants for these
patients since this is a de novo and
then 44 homozygote variances patient
that actually not that important because
you're not expecting to find the neural
almost like a change
and also there is a 484 possible
mutations in his sample and we use a
disappoint parent and we excluded all
the variants and reparative parents are
heterozygous or homozygous for this
variance and we ended up hearing 8 8
hitters I got variants that could be
possible rotation for this programs so
you can see it if we can illuminate the
Lots is fitted for the dominant model an
x-linked model is as kind of the
frequencies similar to the recessive we
use one posts about percent population
frequency and this model you only focus
the variance on the X chromosome and
then if you if you've owned those are
only 22 for these patients and if you
filter out there anything that father
carriers or the mom is homozygote then
your ending up having only two off
aliens that could be possible okay then
after all this filtering steps now we
have around 150 maybe variants to go
over for this patient and then in the
clinical scenario usually the focus on
the genes that's been published in the
FGM your army because those are the
genes are being described well and
linked to the disorders that will be
useful for the patients to interpret
otherwise it will be very difficult if
there is no functional studies or
phenotypic information of the gene and
it will be very difficult in the
clinical world to interpret those
results it will be done something is
different than research so in this
patient actually patient had eight r1d a
RI d1b gene mutation and this is a stop
codon mutation it's a dino or Dino
variant
the example of the RTV viewer you see
that the g2 Tia it recycled change and
we actually use the standard to confirm
this mutation as well and okay if we
found one Dino or possible mutation and
then ok the next question is is this
stop codon rotation or is this genius
that is causing to the patient so there
are two basic questions actually need to
be answered is the students well
described like I said before in the
apartment google or hgmd is as any finna
typical link and then after you figure
out that answer that you have to end ask
the question is this mutation is well
described as well so you need to look
the petitioner to scoring saved
qualifying mutation taster or
conservation again in pubmed and
google's are really useful tools to
describe the and categorize the mutation
cottage in utility based on the
available information in the research
side on if you go back to the art
patient this patient operation had a
stop codon mutation in a are ideal one
be gene so when we look at the PubMed we
found the nature to this article in 2012
and there were Dino bug to include
mutations in this gene it called a dis
patients actually has a coffin series
syndrome so this was a good evidence for
us to see this potential exists you need
to agree to this clinical phenotype and
I'm time you look at this coffin
students syndrome to see how much
overlap with our patients phenotype
coughing series is a global
developmental delay short stature
hypotonia and some learning difficulties
really overlap our patients phenotype so
we felt really good about or dissipation
and then since this is a stop codon
mutation it was a little bit easier to
classify and in fact that there was an
article that describe the stop codon
mutations in this gene caused a
conference series syndrome so we ended
up reporting in this patient the
volatile photogenic mutation that is
predictably causative for the patient's
symptoms was detected so here's one
tricky um hang in there in the stop
codon mutations sometimes when you see
the stop codon mutations you can think
that's okay this is the stop codon
mutations come to the disease-causing
which actually we might not be the case
for all the time so some every healthy
individuals may have couple of stop
codon mutations and also some of the
genes even the battle described
disease-causing mutations in the genes
it can this is cause if those jeans the
disease mechanism is a hablar is not a
hopeless efficiency of the
gain-of-function then actually stop
codon mutations may not cause that
disorder as well so you really need to
look for the disease mechanism in
similar examples able to make that
conclusion that the stop codon can it
can disease-causing that's little bit
tricky okay so that was the first
example for for the forge coughing
syndrome and what about imprinted genes
that's really interesting aspects
because you really need to analyze those
genes in different a different set of
mind it's not a recessive or dominant
are excellent inheritance it's a
imprinted gene Elizabeth you're on a
pattern that you have to really look for
it so patient may carry the same
rotation with one of the healthy parents
this rotation can be disease-causing
based on which parent inherited the
mutation solve
here's one example that I think it's
very interesting we had a case with the
three years old male and this patient
had growth delay proportional
microcephaly and autism spectrum
disorder and some multiple congenital
anomalies and parents describe this hey
there son is a breaking out the smiles
and laughter for no reason so we
received a patient and also parent and
for exxon testing so when we analyze the
data this time we actually we always
look the imprint of jeans so yeah this
time we'll look the imprinted gene as
well and we found there is a missense
mutation in in this patient care system
is a mutation in the ube3a g is actually
one of the imprinted genes and for
Angelyn syndrome and this healthy mom
also carries this notation so and it's
really tricky because of the engine one
if you have if he inherited your
mutation from your mother you can you
can have the disorder if we inherit the
same notation from your father so you
may not have the disorder it's the same
attention if you United from your mother
and you'll have the disorder so that
kind of explain the mom cannot be can be
carrier but not have the disorder so
this is a mutation that has been 300,000
in the population and we use the
mutilation prediction programs like a
sieve Polly final taste there to see the
pathogenetic and it kind of supports
opportunity and conserve and you see on
the left upper corner of this slide that
it's there
the GTH guetta to change and we confirm
this mutation to GTA change and we
confirm this mutation and by Sanger
sequencing as well so and then at this
step you really need require you to do
more work up to able to confirm this a
disease-causing mutations and in this
scenario the grandparent will be good to
test for this specific mutation to see
the model clear a inherited mutation
either from her father or her mother so
that will give us a information if she
reads the mutation from her father that
actually supports the possibility of
this mutation if she inherited that from
her mother this actually tells us that
this is not a potentially quotation this
is actually just a benign variant if you
look at the Angela moon syndrome
actually angelman syndrome phenotype is
very much overlap in our patients
patients phenotype angel my patients may
have a laughing and some hands moment as
well so this is just an example of the
imprinted genes and analyzing and
different perspective okay so when you
have the exam you have to know special
the clinicians need to know this is it
doesn't mean that you have results for
everything so there are lots of
limitations or the exon testing as well
so on my own exam is not able to
complete the analyze it some jeans and
nothing identified that which may not
seek us not all photogenic mutations are
killing the exon all the most of them so
those are really the limitations some
jeans parts of genes may not the other
kill to sequence the low for coffee
analysis and mutations are located in
jeans with corresponding pseudogenes
some repetitive or hi GC regions large
deletions or duplications and also
mosaic mutations may not detectable some
of the exon testing and if you're not
really target on the mitochondrial DNA
and you may not get the result of the
sequencing and chromosomal phase of
identified photogenic mutations may not
be identified and you have to have the
parent able to analyze this way and mode
of inheritance with its patrons gently
ketogenic introduced the clinical
sensitivity as well on the reporting
sites there are some limitations as well
so all the mutations and variants are
curing in no no new jeans or heme jeans
or the genes have been linked to the
phenotype could be actually really
interpret better than other genes so
incorrect reported biological
relationships among family members are
necessary for proper result
interpretation if this been given wrong
for to the laboratory the resulting
actually misleading as well so in X home
see because it may not identify the
cause of the patient's result even if
the storage is a genetic condition so
those are really the limitations of the
exome sequencing so from now on I will
switch the talk and i'll talk about
little bit guidelines and regulations
about six months ago there were not
really much guidelines or regulations
that the laboratory can follow but this
phase is we are really good if very
lucky that we have several guidelines
that we can follow and
and do validations and regulations and
right now the cap is a checklist that we
can follow and American College of
medical genetics actually published the
clinical laboratory standards for next
generation sequencing in this month of
the genetics of Medicine so we can
follow those guidelines and clear
clinical laboratory Improvement
Amendments also published there ensuring
the quality of NGS in the laboratory
practice as well okay this is a really I
wanted to talk about little bit
incidental findings a couple of months
ago American College of medical genetics
and genomics published recommendation
for reporting incidental findings this
is really very new and unique guidelines
never being able to a published such a
guideline before and in this industry
coronation they want laboratory return
the results of if the mutations in 57
genes they elicit those genes in one by
one and those genes are associated to
the increased risk of 24 series series
of treatable diseases even if the
clinicians do not suspect the patients
have these disorders so what are
incidental findings when Stanton
findings are defining self variants the
font by exome and genome sequencing
which are unrelated to the disease of
interest although majority of them are
benign however there are some of them
could be really disease associated
mutations and based on my experience
every most of the patients may have one
or between one and five incidental
findings that
we actually do it with their their
disorder which not related the patient's
phenotype although it's called
incidental findings this working group
and recommended the laboratory actively
search for this rotation so it's not
accidentally found in the data analysis
they want a laboratory specific new look
just 57 mutations in this 57 jeans and
see if the patients have photogenic
mutations in these jeans and report them
out those are the those are the
mandatory reporting foreign-owned
rotations for the disorders such as his
tail cancers Marfan syndrome long QT
syndrome or goddess enrollment certain
cut my abilities so but they really want
you the report on the day if in
photogenic known pathogenic mutations
they don't want to laboratory report if
that anything is uncertain our unknown
variant in front on this 57 jeans okay
here is a discussion of course and about
this recommendation so where the patient
autonomy comes here one of and patients
right not to know the result so I'm sure
there will be lots of discussions and
will be continuing on on several years
that the this recommendation a working
group is recommending them reporting
even reporting in and the children as
well so recommendation for sickening
reporting in standard findings not
limited by the age of the person being
seacoast so they believe that the
prevention of harmful diseases outweigh
the ethical concern
so they want reports some children's
invitations even though those are
disorders that it of adult onset disease
some of these such as some of the cancer
disorders so 10 despite some discussions
about the instant own findings exome
sequencing is a great potential for
diagnosing diseases of unknown etiology
possibly leading to improved to
implementation care and quality control
measures data analysis and reporting of
instance of findings and continuity
evolve and improve so I'm from right now
I'll stop and I'll be happy to answer
any questions if you be right down and
if you want to get the credit then you
need to go this website to to collect
the credits thank you very much so I'm
looking at if there is any question has
been submitted so far and I don't see
any question needs and i'll be i'll be
waiting a little bit longer to see if
dari if you like to submit a question
okay i did i see one question it knows
okay okay here's one of one question and
what had been your achievement so far in
this field and so like i said it's a
diagnostic yield is around 20 person
based on the nih studies and based on
our and our group diagonal clinical
sensitivity is also around twenty
twenty-five percent so we really find
photogenic mutation clear-cut pathogenic
mutation in one case in every every 5
case so we're able to help twenty
percent of the patient as well and the
second question I see here what do you
consider base solution for gina Marie
analysis and it's I just don't know what
does it mean reanalysis I guess it's
time I'm assuming this is like when you
seek us the data he analyzed the data
now and couple of years later if there
is enough publication and then and none
if the conditions month you re analyze
the data the existing knowledge and
that's really that's really important
and I do believe that the laboratory may
actually develop some test code for just
three analyzing the existing data in a
couple of years later because I believe
there will be lots of more publications
or research studies may actually help
patience patience motivated petitions
that we may not find at the beginning so
I think that's very useful and
laboratory should just maybe create a
code for that and then the conditions
can order for for that call just a photo
reanalyzing but just keep in your mind
the technology is moving so forward so
fast that actually you may actually
ricci cones and reanalyze instead of
just free and life as well thank you
very much and I'll see if there's any
other questions no yeah I don't see in
other questions yep do the questions
coming in your mind you can still email
me they tell me that this far more for
me but I really don't see it
okay I got it there is one more question
how can you correlate the results in
different genetic mutations with the
epigenetic else aspects and it's really
really difficult question and I guess
you mean with the epigenetic epigenetic
aspects is and it is just like
imprinting but some other and some
others mutilations and it's it's very
difficult to correlate those results and
interpret those results if there is not
enough but there are some kids now
available to look the methylation status
of the of some genes that will be useful
to actually incorporate on on Exum is
not in the exon but you have to really
do some regulation treatments and then
do the sequencing reactions so that
maybe could be useful for the cancer as
well but it's a very hard topic to do
and the clinical site any other
questions okay it looks like there is no
other questions thank you very much for
listening me I hope that was a useful
presentation thank you it could be oh
there is one okay so hey have you ever
worked in neuro criminology and genetics
no I never worked in the neural energy
area and all I work is the inherited
disorders so I don't have any experience
all right thank you very much in a good
day